verdict in johnny depp's defamation suit
against amber heard that's in but the
case continues to play out in the court
of public opinion
a seven-person jury awarded the actor 15
million dollars in damages after finding
her defamed him with an op-ed on
domestic violence christina raffini is
outside the courtroom in fairfax
virginia forest christina everyone's
gotta have an opinion about this one
today good morning
good morning tony yes depp was the
overall winner but it was a surprise
split verdict with herd being awarded
two million dollars in her countersuit
against johnny depp now her team also
plans to appeal but we're told that's
unlikely to be granted at this point
amber heard and her lawyers sat quietly
as they listened to the jury's verdict
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
heard will now have to pay 10 million
dollars in compensatory damages and 350
000 in punitive damages after the
original five million dollar amount was
capped and reduced due to state law
after the verdict the largely pro-dept
crowd cheered his legal team the claims
against johnny depp are defamatory and
unsupported by any evidence i think the
jury followed the evidence in this case
seth berensweig is a business and trial
attorney in northern virginia what was
the hardest part of this case do you
think for depp's team without question
you have to demonstrate that this was
done with a malicious intent very
difficult to do in a case
johnny depp's lawyers slammed that out
of the park
heard and her lawyers didn't speak to
the cameras after the verdict but in a
statement she wrote that she was
heartbroken and the jury's decision
quote sets back the clock to a time when
a woman who spoke up and spoke out could
be publicly humiliated depp was not in
court for the decision choosing to stay
in london for work but in a lengthy
statement of his own he said quote the
jury gave me my life back i am truly
humbled
the live stream trial drew millions of
viewers each week heard testified twice
detailing more than a dozen incidents of
alleged physical and sexual assault
pounding the back of my head pounding it
with his fist depp however maintained
that he never abused herd and that he
was the one who suffered abuse during
their relationship an accusation she
denies she threw the large bottle
the tip of my finger
had been
severed for amber heard she has an
incredibly incredibly difficult road
ahead of her jessie weber is an attorney
and host on the law and crime network he
was in the courtroom during the trial i
don't see her having an a-list career
anymore if she was on her way to stardom
with aquaman and aquaman too i don't see
that happening for her
now heard's team could also try to
negotiate down those damages or even
even ask depp to waive them arguing that
he got what he really wanted and that's
vindication in the court of public
opinion tony
all right christina thank you very much
we're